[موسيقى]
فضل السندات على الاسهم من ناحيه الاسهم
بفضل الاسهم للي هي بسموه فاليوستات يعني
الاسهم القيمه على اسهم لجروس يعني الاسهم
النمو وبعد ما يقدر انه اسهم النمو بعد
غالي غالي على المستويات
وبنتها كثير استثمر فيها وبتوجه صوب اسهم
الصاص وفيما يتعلق بالاسواق الحقيقه انه
بلاقي بعد السوق الامريكي شويه عالي وتفضل
الاسماء الاوروبيه خصوصا باول فصل ثاني
فصل على الاسواق الامريكيه فيما يتعلق
بالاسهم وكمان باول فصل او ثاني فصل فضل
الاسواق الناشئه على الاسواق الدول ال-
ال- المتقدمه
[موسيقى]
راي نسبه السندات لازم تكون بالكرتون
حاليا حول الخمسين او 60%
[موسيقى]
امريكا براي الاسعار راح تكون للخمسه 5.25
والدرجيم تقريبا سنه ونصف في اوروبا رحل
بنك المركزي على الفوائد اكثر من الناس
متوقع يعني براي راح يوصلوا ل 3:30
بانجلترا راح يسر الى 44 فاصل 5% همم
بالاقتصادات الناشئه انا برايي الفوائد
هلا صارت بوضع جيد مثل ما هي وراح ينتظره
انه يشوفوا وقع انه مول اقتصادي على على
بلدانون قبل ما يتحركوا على الفوائد